when you're in the zone you're expanding
your skills in a manner that's
intrinsically rewarding because you're
succeeding you have a lot of potential
as a child but none of that is capable
of manifesting itself as freedom before
you become disciplined first of all you
have to treat yourself like you matter
because if you don't then you don't take
care of yourself and you become vengeful
and and and cruel Juanes or get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best jordan peterson and how to find
meaning in your life mentor me Jordan
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one set up the criteria for success but
one of the main reasons that people do
get what they want is because they don't
actually figure out what it is and the
probability that you're going to get
what would be good for you let's say
which would even be better than what you
want right because you know you might be
what wrong about what you want easily
but maybe you could get what would
really be good for you well why don't
you well cuz you don't try you don't
think okay here's what I would like if I
could have it and and I don't mean I
don't mean in a way that you manipulate
the world to force it to deliver you
goods for status or something like that
that isn't what I mean I mean something
like imagine that you were taking care
of yourself like you were someone you
actually cared for and then you thought
okay I'm caring for this person I would
like things to go as well for them as
possible
what would their life have to be like in
order for that to be the case well
people don't do that they don't sit down
and think alright you know let's let's
figure it out you've got a life it's
hard obviously it's like three years
from now you can have what you need
you've got to be careful about it you
can't have everything you can have what
would be good for you but you have to
figure out what it is and then you have
to aim at it well my experience with
people as being is if they figure out
what it is that would be good for them
and then they aim at it then they get it
and it's strange because they don't
necessarily an idea about what would be
good for you and then you take ten steps
towards that and you find out that your
formulation was a bit off and so you
have to reformulate your goal you know
you're kind of going like this as you
move towards the goal but a huge part of
the reason that people fail is because
they don't ever set up the criteria for
success and so since success is a very
narrow line and very unlikely the
probability that you're going to stumble
on it randomly is
and so there's a proposition here in the
proposition is if you actually want
something you can have it now the
question then would be well what do you
mean by actually want and the answer is
that you reorient your life in every
possible way
to make the probability that that will
occur as certain as possible and that's
a sacrificial idea right it's like you
don't get everything obviously you
obviously but maybe you can have what
you need and maybe all you have to do to
get it is ask but asking isn't a whim or
today's wish it's like you have to be
deadly serious about it you have to
think okay like I'm taking stock of
myself and if I was going to live
properly in the world and I was going to
set myself up such that being would
justify itself in my estimation and I
don't mean as a harsh judge exactly what
is it that I would aim at sit on your
bed one day and ask yourself what's what
remarkably stupid things am i doing on a
regular basis to absolutely screw up my
life and if you actually ask that
question but you have to want to know
the answer right because that's actually
what asking the question means it
doesn't mean just mouthing the words it
means you have to decide that you want
to know you'll figure that's out so fast
it'll make your hair curl rule number
two set goals properly tell your kid
here's an impossible thing why don't you
go out and fail you say here's something
worth going after here's a step you
could take that would push you beyond
where you are but that you also have a
reasonably high probability of
succeeding at right they called that
within a time frame it's in some
timeframe that's the other thing you
have to parameterize it with regards to
time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that says that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named Vygotsky he was
a Russian developmental psychologist and
the smart one that's where the idea of
the zone comes from to be in the zone
and when you're in the zone you're
expanding your skills in a manner that's
intrinsically rewarding because
you're succeeding and so you want to set
if you're good to yourself you think
okay I need to set a goal but I need to
set a goal that someone is stupid and
useless as me could probably attain if
they put some effort into it and then
you got it then you've got it perfectly
because it's not so high that it's
grandiose or impossible that you fail
necessarily and then justify your
bitterness it's like well I couldn't do
it well because that happens to Pete how
much all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well I
set a goal and I didn't attain it so I'm
not gonna set any more goal right it's
like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you want it to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
that's why I'm being a victim mmm yeah
which isn't in helpful you're still
gonna be a victim there's still a way
out of that man so yeah you know because
life is this life is a challenge that in
some sense can't be surmounted so
there's no way out of your problem but
there are certainly proper ways of
dealing with it yeah also if you want
more confidence check out my to 54
confidence series it's free the link is
in the description below if you're gonna
speak effectively you have to know way
more than you're talking about rule
number three become disciplined we kind
of have this idea that while you're free
as a child and then you let me see if I
can if I can put this properly that you
have a certain delightful wonderful
positive freedom as a child and then
that's given up as you approach
adulthood but the truth of the matter is
is that you have a lot of potential as a
child but none of that is capable of
manifesting itself as freedom before you
become disciplined and discipline is a
matter of the imposition of order and
the order is necessary especially for
people who are hopeless and nihilistic
and lots of people are hopeless and
nihilistic way more people than you
think and part of that is because no
one's ever really encouraged them and so
the book is in part a matter of
encouragement it's like lay yourself lay
a disciplinary structure on yourself get
the chaos in in in check and then you
can move towards a state that's freer
because it's discipline first like look
if you're going to become a concert
pianist there's going to be several
thousand hours of extra
discipline practice that's the
imposition of order on your potential
let's say but what comes out of that is
a much grander freedom and so in
virtually every freedom that you have in
life that's true freedom is purchased at
the price of discipline and rule number
four the last one before a very special
bonus clip is treat yourself like you
matter first of all you have to treat
yourself like you matter because if you
don't then you don't take care of
yourself and you become vengeful and and
and cruel and you you take you take it
out on people around you and you're not
a positive force none of that's good
so you suffer more and so does everyone
around you and there's a malevolence
that enters into it
none of that's good so that's what
happens if you don't treat yourself like
you matter and then what happens if you
don't treat other people like they
matter
well you lie to them you cheat them you
steal you you you enter into impulsive
relationships with them they can't trust
you that doesn't go anywhere they don't
like you you you end up alone at best
and maybe like incarcerated at worst
like that doesn't work and so you watch
the people around you who thrive
regardless of what they say they act out
the proposition that everyone matters
and then you have a functional Society
and I think okay well if if if when you
act out the proposition that everyone
matters you have a functional Society
maybe that's evidence that that
proposition is true it's like I think
it's I think it's true now I've got a
special bonus gift from Jordan Peterson
on how to start small that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions time to go from just watching
a video to taking action here we go
question number one what will you do to
treat yourself like you matter number
two where do you need to become more
disciplined and number three what are
the criteria for success for you I know
you stated in the last lecture that the
importance for setting aims in life and
to kind of have goals to work towards
right so my question was
where do you how do you do that if you
don't know where you want to go because
that's kind of where I got stuck on your
your future off offering program because
okay that's that's a good question
that's a really good question so there's
this notion in the Old Testament that
morality is following a sequence of
prohibitions there's a bunch of bad
things you shouldn't do and then
basically you're good enough and and and
I think there's wisdom in that I think
that's kind of where children start
right you I mean I love children and all
that but they're they're they're crazy
little creatures and they need to be you
know civilized and partly what you do is
you you lay prohibitions on them and
mostly what you're trying to do is lay
prohibitions on them for the behaviors
that if they manifested would make their
life miserable so this is why this thing
that I've said the people has become
this crazy internet meme but that's to
clean up your room and which which is a
lot better and more useful than people
think it's a lot harder to but the thing
the first thing you do I think and I
learned this in part from Solzhenitsyn
when he was trying to iron out his soul
when he was in the gulag because he was
trying to figure out how he got there
how he contributed to how he got there
you know not Stellan and Hitler even
though they were kind of to blame you
know but he wasn't much he could do
about that I think what you have to do
and this is part of humility is you have
to look around you within your sphere of
influence like the direct sphere of
influence and fix the things that
announce themselves as in need of repair
and those are often small things you
know and they can be like your room put
it in order because the thing is it
isn't exactly so important that your
room is in order although it is what's
important is that you learn how to
distinguish between chaos and order and
to be able to act in a manner that
produces order and I think you can you
can do something as simple as just sit
on your bed and think okay there's
probably like five things I could do
today so that tomorrow morning is
slightly better than this morning was at
least or at least I'm not falling behind
and those will usually be it's like
having to eat a toad in the morning
right it's like it's not gonna be
something you want to do there'll be
things you're trying to avoid there's
snakes essentially but if you ask
yourself like you're asking someone
which i think is a form of
prayer if you ask yourself instead of
telling yourself you know what is it
that I could do to set things more right
today that I would actually do it's
usually some small thing because he's
not that disciplined you know then you
can go do it and then you be put the
world together a little more when you do
that and that spreads out but you also
put your you also construct yourself
into something that's better able to
call order forth from chaos and that
makes you just incrementally stronger
and then the next day you can maybe take
on a slightly larger task and like you
get the benefit of compound interest if
you do that it's a tremendously powerful
technique and they think if you do that
at some point instead of just having to
fix things up that are not good you'll
start to get a glimmer of the positive
things that you could do you know the
positive things that you could do that
would actually constitute a vision and
now that's what I would recommend
if you want more Jordan Peterson check
out the top ten rules video I made
underhand the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there it's
important to distinguish between those
because that's partly and this is back
down to the micro routine analysis so as
I say while you're gonna try to make
yourself more industrious okay number
one